alright now let's come back proposed
aliens for and against the use of this
particular concept so I just gave you
some write the length of time it takes
to develop because just has to go
through and try and try and try again
okay but also the fact that it can learn
is great because not only can it
actually adjust itself in response to
what you know but later on once you've
trained the system okay
it could recount new situations that
you've never encountered before
and make a prediction and recommend a
decision on the basis of that base you
know even if it's never seen it before
it's only had this expected data okay
that's really really good that's kind of
the idea of an expert system that we're
trying to get at right now new networks
and expert systems both designed by
humans software engineers contrast the
relationships between these two sets of
designers okay
now we're kind of getting a distant just
now how would you articulate the
difference between them let's start with
this with these three okay mushy meat
dessert how much what kind of level of
input do they have to the structure and
function of the decision support system
in these three cases what can we be any
more specific and lots cuz lots is
accurate but it's vague okay yeah they
have total control total control if
there's something in one of these
systems it's because a programmer put it
there okay it's because you actually
typed it in the formula or you designed
the tables and their relationships okay
or you decide the the knowledge base and
how it would read the database of facts
or the inference engine you chose it
backward chaining forward chaining and
so on okay so total control
okay whereas the designer for an
artificial new network right what's
their job it's kind of like they're
feeding an animal right all you have to
do is give it data now you do have to
pick the right data okay so you've got
to select that you can't just give it
anything right you want to give it a
good set of data but that's the
different kind of relation
ship right so the real structure and
function is actually being decided by
the artificial neural network itself
okay now that feeds right into number
four once you've got in your network and
it's trained up and it's good at making
decisions right sometimes it'll make a
decision and the designer won't be able
to explain why it made that decision
which is a big contrast to the expert
system which has its explanation
mechanism which is designed for that
specific purpose so why not how can that
be you know the designer design it so
how can they not be able to explain okay
yeah right so it's it's it's almost like
a brute force kind of approach right
okay now let's go after that the
explanation mechanism do you remember
see if we can revise this because this
is a bit trickier the explanation
mechanism right what data does it draw
on to give its justification to give its
explanation where does it go
okay go machen that's a nice my sisters
right you need to know this one it goes
to all the other parts and it takes
particular bits of the other components
of the expert system to explain number
one it says okay look the database of
fats right it says you gave me all these
piece of information maybe he gave me a
hundred pieces of information but it was
these twenty that you told me about that
we're really important to the decision I
was going to be okay so it goes through
that basis of fact and it pulls out the
relevant details for this situation okay
remember that yes now these relevant
details right they interact with the
knowledge base what was in the knowledge
base what does the knowledge base
contain yeah that's right so it's got
its got a set of rules that determine
how it understands a scenario right and
only some of them the ones that relate
to the details right will be activated
will be fired okay so it will say what
were their relevant rules okay and then
of course it goes to the inference
engine right and it says okay how did
you actually execute those rules and
how's that actually explained what kind
of decision you made the end okay now
therefore once an expert system makes
this kind of decision it will present
this as evidence it will say look see
this is exactly why you I'll tell you
why I made this decision it's because of
this piece of logic that you put in men
right or this particular detail is
provided by the client on the other hand
the Neill Network right what explanation
is it gonna give do you remember the
structure that was illustrated right
what you've got is your inputs on the
left-hand side
okay by the way this is a really
important diagram that you need to get
you've got a few inputs here you've got
to get some outputs over here and then
in this in-between space you've got all
these nodes that are connected to each
other but artificial neurons right
because they're kind of doing this
literally this sort of black magic sort
of thing which we don't really
understand that's why it's
we sort of cloud right the heated nerds
so the mechanics of this is not
understood by the new network designer
necessarily okay not only is it sort of
doing its job to work out its weightings
at its transfer functions on its own but
it might just be so complicated that
even if you did understand all the bits
they wouldn't be able to actually say oh
yeah this is why right it's just so
complex just like a human brain is okay